tucker carlson made a
an allegation two nights ago he said
that
the nsa was spying on him he heard about
it from a whistleblower
and uh they are planning to leak
his communications and they want to take
a show off of the air
the nsa this is really shocking that
they would do this they actually did
issue
a statement on this
now the nsa's statement on tucker
carlson first of all it's
pretty strange that the nsa would even
comment on this
if a if a fox news host or any other
news host for that matter
makes an allegation why would the
national security agency
feel obliged to come out and defend
itself
or maybe not defend itself as you'll see
from the missive
is it because they they feel a little
guilty is it because they know that
where there's smoke there's fire is it
because they fear what tucker carlson
has been told
we know for example that the nsa has
spied on
virtually everybody in the sense that
they're collecting
huge amounts of data and the pretext for
this is they want to make sure
that they monitor uh foreign governments
and people you know people
who have business affairs with
foreigners so
they're collecting all of this data
tucker carlson says
no they're they're specifically looking
at my stuff
so here is the nsa's denial
pay attention to the wording here on
june 28th
2021 tucker carlson alleged that the
national security agency has been quote
monitoring our electronic communications
and is planning to leak them
in an attempt to take this show off the
air this allegation is
untrue tucker carlson has never been an
intelligence target of the agency
and the nsa has never had any plans to
try to take his program off the air
next paragraph nsa has a foreign
intelligence mission we target foreign
powers to generate insights on foreign
activities
that could harm the united states with
limited exceptions for example an
emergency nsa
may not target a u.s citizen without a
court order that explicitly authorizes
the targeting
now if you're not paying attention to
words you know
there's a great book out right now about
how we need to be really precise about
our language
and it uh it's actually on the the uh
charts this week it's charted
uh we'll we'll get into that a little
bit later the book is called speech
listening forwards controlling minds
thank you to those who ordered it
if you're not paying close attention to
words you might say okay they're denying
it right
not so fast in their own denial
they point out that tucker has made
three allegations
the nsa is monitoring monitoring his
communications the nsa is planning to
leak them
the nsa is doing so in an attempt to
take the show off the air
now the the nsa specifically says this
allegation
is untrue which allegation
there are three allegations if
you say this allegation is untrue then
you're lumping them all together
so you're saying no we're not monitoring
your communications and planning to leak
them in order to take your show off the
air so if
any any single part or even two parts of
that
broad allegation could be true and the
nsa could still not be lying by saying
this allegation isn't let's say that
they are monitoring tucker
and they're planning to leak them but
it's not to take his show off the air
well then that allegation's not true
let's say they're monitoring tucker but
they don't really plan to leak them or
take a [ __ ] okay well then that
allegation is not true
even further what they say is tucker
carlson has never been an
intelligence target of the agency
they're not saying they've never spied
on him they're not saying that they're
not spying on him right now they're
saying
they're not targeting him maybe they're
targeting someone
that he's speaking to and oops whoopsie
daisy i guess tucker's communications
are coming through as well
to me that's and they look at how many
times they use the word target never
been a target of the agency they may not
target a u.s citizen without an order
that authorizes the targeting
why are they using that language the
people who are doing this the spies the
spooks they're actually pretty
sophisticated i don't know if you ever
heard about that
and people whose job it is to deceive
are actually pretty good at deceiving
if they were not spying on tucker i bet
they would say that
i bet they would actually just come out
and say it if
they were not either monitoring him
or planning to end or planning to leak
that and or planning to take your show
trying to take a show off the air
i think they would say that i think they
would say these allegations
are untrue tucker has never been
surveilled by the nsa tucker is not
to me reading this it is
quite clear that the nsa is in fact
conducting surveillance that involves
tucker carlson
and they may or may not be planning to
leak it and
i'm sure plenty of people at the end as
they want to take a show off the air
because he's an actual threat to them
jen saki was asked about this this is
further evidence that the nsa is
obviously looking into tucker carlson
the white house was asked about this and
she refused to deny it
tucker carlson said that the nsa is
spying on him
is the administration aware of any
or listening efforts on u.s citizens by
the nsa and is tucker carlson one of
them
uh well the nsa as i think you're well
aware i'm
sure everyone's aware everyone on this
plane is aware i should say
uh is an entity that focuses on foreign
threats
and individuals who are trying
attempting to do us harm on foreign soil
so
uh that is the their uh purview um but
uh beyond that i would point you to the
intelligence community
what what oh man it's like if you're
gonna
deceive people at least be like the
person at the nsa don't be like jen saki
who doesn't even
who doesn't even really try or doesn't
even come close to succeeding
hey is the nsa spying on tucker carlson
well
um you know the nsa is
uh it's three letter three three that's
a three-letter word
um it stands for national security
agency
um it's got employees um they some of
them have pensions
uh and so okay i feel like i've answered
your question um
what no i didn't ask what is the nsa i
said is the nsa spying on tucker carlson
well um you know the nsa and you know
what what they're trying to deflect to
is they're saying
the nsa uh focuses on foreign threats
so what's the implication tucker's
he's colluding with the russians or the
ukrainians or whatever he's
or anybody he's this is the same old
story same stuff different day
the reason the reason that the federal
government had to spy on the trump
campaign
had to spy on its political opponents is
because
they were colluding with the russians
okay well where's the proof what what
crime did they commit they well
um none none they conducted what
several years long millions and millions
of dollars spent to just try to
prove anything like they got him right
there's got to be some connection
trump ate borscht one time a few years
ago didn't he no they didn't even have
that
they didn't even have that but that's
the excuse we have to make sure he could
be
he he talked to his falafel court driver
down the street that's he's talking to a
foreigner
got to get him pretty quick unless the
nsa and the white house can do better
than this
i think the only conspiracy theory is
that the nsa is not spying on tucker
carlson
they've all but admitted that just
dodging
the question hold up glad you liked that
video
go check out the whole episode it's
right here it's called pay no attention
to the man behind the curtain you can
also get it on apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play all the places
for your audio podcast and most
importantly of all
after you like and subscribe and leave
comment you can go order my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
it's the number one book in civil rights
right now i am the number one civil
rights leader in the country
go check it out i'll see you next time
[Music]
you